human love the doll not long ago he was
a university student but Teemo boots
soon tired of attending lectures and
studying math he was interested in
electronics and decided to train as an
apprentice now he's helping construct a
fuse box for a hospital as a help in a
gigabyte Almaty I started off studying
energy building services and
environmental engineering but quickly
realized that it's quite theoretical and
includes all sorts of subjects that
didn't interest me I was interested in
electronics and decided to apprentice in
that there were no students again this
company is happy to have him three of
its apprenticeship positions went
unfilled this year for lack of
applicants the family business builds
electrical systems for companies
government offices and other public
facilities the firm keeps growing and
the boss would like to take on more
trainees especially university dropouts
like Timo it's
yes I'm Foshan Gazette star he's more
calm and collected and after quitting
University he knows what he wants he's
picked a new career path in something he
can handle and that's something younger
people don't know for sure yet they're a
bit more Restless we go for visa bill
her firm is located on the outskirts of
Minster a university town with all the
young people around you'd think it would
be easy to fill apprenticeships but most
high school grads enroll at University
instead however many later do quit 1/4
of all students across Germany now the
country's employment agency is targeting
these college dropouts like 27 year-old
Yulia aapke 9 who's come for a
consultation
you get and how are you I'm still very
undecided
unfortunately my studies are over I
don't have a master's and urgently need
an alternative a new vocation that I'd
be more suited to and which I can handle
ya leaked was yet elation after seven
years she quit her teacher training
course it was a relief it was goofy yeah
I always had the feeling I couldn't do
it kept putting off the assignments and
the exams I didn't want to go see my
instructors anymore and it took me a
while to realize that I was unhappy with
my studies de pez Pakeha god damn it
bothered me that my future was being a
teacher that it was all predetermined
inside I realized that it wasn't for me
that I couldn't be happy doing this for
the next 40 years it's a gentleman maha
invasion ish don't guessed the ultimate
now she wants to train to be a software
developer job counselor Molly Anna única
has dealt with many such cases in which
young people spend years studying things
they don't like
hem loafer yeah but over the years they
get a much better idea of their
interests and strengths and develop the
courage to explore areas better suited
to their personality and interests me I
yell a bazooka an interesting education
team Oats is done for the day in a year
and a half he'll take his exams and
become an electronics technician does he
ever regret dropping out of college no I
found it fun no not at all if you have
one office many of my friends are
students and I see what they're doing
and I'm not jealous in the least sorry
Molotov in Ethiopia Schneider scuba
wouldn't I see them sitting at their
desks and learning when I have time off
Leonce oven itself I often listen so for
me it's absolutely not a problem that
they're students and I'm not anymore
while his friends hit the books Teemo
it's can enjoy his leisure time and is
already earning money and once he
becomes a master electronics technician
his income will rival that of many
university graduates